جاء حماري
ذهب حماري
بالفرحة ينهق في الدار
ويشاركني
كل همومي
ويرافقني في أسفاري
جاء حماري  جاء حماري
ذهب حماري ذهب حماري
بالفرحة ينهق في الدار
ويشاركني ويشاركني
كل همومي كل همومي
ويرافقني في أسفاري
كان جحا يمشي ويغني  وأندهش صغار وكبار
سألته زوجته قالت
منذ متى ولدينا حمار
يا امرأتي اليوم سأجلبه  إعتبريه هنا موجود
قل يا جحا إن شاء الله
لما هكذا عقلك محدود
المال بجيبي والسوق  بالقرب فلماذا الضيق
وعلام القلق يراودني  سأجلبه لا شيء يعيق
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
قل يا جحا ان شاء الله
مر الوقت وعاد جحا  يلطم يصرخ واغوثااه
هرعت زوجته تسأله
لما أنت حزين يا جحا
سرق اللص المال وهرب
ما صار بجيبي موجود
لم أسمع نصحك يا امرأتي
فأنا من عقله محدود
لم أذكر إن شاء الله
ان شاء الله ان شاء الله
قل يا جحا ان شاء الله